the guy who is supposedly for free
speech and against safe spaces against
political correctness against language
policing is refusing to visit the United
Kingdom unless Prime Minister Theresa
May can ensure Donald Trump that there
will be no protests of his visit or he
is simply not going to go a Bloomberg is
also reporting that when they spoke on
the phone
Donald Trump complained to the prime
minister of the UK Theresa May that
there is negative coverage of him in the
press and Theresa may rightly said yeah
that's how the UK media operates and I'm
not able to change that myself and
reportedly the advisers who were
listening on that phone call were quote
astonished at what Donald Trump was
saying to her can you even imagine this
absurdity of course she would never do
it but just imagine for a second that
Theresa May announced during Donald
Trump's visit protests will not be
allowed period it would lead to the
biggest protests in a very long time in
the UK free speech is great for the u.s.
I guess according to Trump but the UK
needs to curtail it for Donald Trump's
thin skin and this is the sort of total
lack of tact and common sense that Trump
has even if your Trump and you're
thinking and I really don't want
protests you don't say it because you
sort of understand that peaceful
protesting is a cherished aspect of
Western democracies but Trump just
straight-up says it because he has
absolutely no understanding of the
context into which he's making such a
request have you ever seen a president
this thin-skinned and it's particularly
funny because the committed Trump is see
Trump as a guy who's tough and he's not
afraid to tell it like it is and Trump
himself has tried really hard to
cultivate this view of him check out
this interview this was from writing
that in the heat of the campaign with
Jake Tapper where he talked about how
thick-skinned he actually is one of the
things one of the things she said was
this is not someone who should have the
nuclear codes it's not hard to imagine
Donald Trump leading us into war because
someone got under his very thin skin
what's your response well first of all I
don't have thin skin I have very strong
very thick skin and when somebody's
right about me I always you know if you
do a report and it's not necessarily
positive but you're right I never
complained I do complain when it's a lie
or when it's wrong but I have a strong
temperament and it's a very good
temperament and it's a very in control
temperament but I wouldn't have built
this unbelievable company I wouldn't
have built all of the things that I've
been able to do in life I've been number
one bestsellers he has the strongest
thickest skin I I don't even know where
to go I was thinking about Obama you
know and when Obama would go overseas
he was great greeted pretty favorably
right
he you could disagree with Obama's
policies but objectively he did
resuscitate the reputation of the u.s.
around the world he would go to Germany
he would go to so many places people
would come out and cheer Obama and maybe
Trump is aware of that he's aware of a
lot of the things Obama did it seemed to
be something of an obsession for him and
maybe that's part of this he wants to be
treated like Obama well it's weird to me
because Trump has done plenty of state
visits he went to Saudi Arabia
he went to Israel and Germany and France
and he visited Duterte his buddy out in
the Philippines and he was protested in
a lot of those places yeah but I mean is
it does the UK really stand out too
distinctly from the rest of those
countries I know they had a petition in
that country of 1.8 million people
signing on to ban tribe and Trump
humming I don't know I I don't know why
it's so particular it's it's
particularly an obsession when it comes
to the UK I don't know the answer to
that we may be part of it as Obama was
the first u.s. president ever invited to
make an address at Westminster Hall in
the UK and now you've got like Pat said
nearly 2 million people who are trying
to keep Trump out of the country
nevermind debt at Westminster Hall I
don't know I don't know what what the
answer is but Trump clearly very very
triggered by the possibility of these
protests special snowflake Trump highly
triggered it would be highly ironic I
would say if the welcoming of the US
president was met with something that
was completely on American which is the
policy that you can't speak openly
you can't protest right right which
actually was sort of the situation when
he went to Saudi Arabia like that's the
place that if you're look
looking for places where people will be
banned from protesting you it's usually
not the countries that we try to aspire
to be like in the United States today's
program is sponsored in part by e
harmony if you're trying online dating
there's a good chance that you've run
into lazy text messages dead-end
conversations random matches that just
never turn into dates and unlike many
other online dating sites a harmony
actually uses years of science data and
psychological research in order to find
you a more compatible match and because
e harmony is built to help you find
lasting meaningful relationships it's
not one of those shallow hookup sites
and they've helped over a million people
find their perfect match
and right now david pakman show
listeners and viewers can get a month of
harmony for free when you sign up for a
three month subscription just enter my
code Pakman at checkout stop waiting
start your journey to a satisfying
meaningful relationship it can be fun to
play around with online dating apps but
when you're ready for a meaningful
relationship there's one app that's
built to bring you exactly that and it's
a harmony see how a harmony can change
your life a harmony calm enter my code
Pakman at checkout PA que ma N